as I predicted Tuesday evening the
Republican line of defense regarding
president Trump's myriad foibles has
boiled down to this Trump is a victim
he's a victim of the press he's a victim
of spineless Republicans who will impact
his play he's a victim of the deep state
in a world of snowflakes Trump is a
veritable one-man Blizzard here is the
sad truth president Trump is a victim of
himself
our Republicans have to deal with
basically the same enemies the media
Mitt Romney was targeted as a bad man
for supposedly strapping a dog to the
top of his car and forcibly cutting a
gay kid's hair back in 1720 John McCain
was allegedly a doddering old crazy
person who wouldn't survive a term in
office george w bush was a war criminal
who sold blood for oil and murdered
hundreds of thousands of people to get
Halliburton some walking-around money
spineless republicans remember
Republicans weren't willing to defend
george w bush during his administration
they were plentiful and they included
many of the same players as they do now
which was uncouth according to many of
these people he had lied people had died
in fact one of the spineless Republicans
who jumped on the bandwagon against bush
was a fellow who had expressed tepid
support for the Iraq war then turned on
Bush with a vengeance when things
started to go south
some guy named Donald Trump as for
congressional Republicans they wouldn't
even ran through Social Security
privatization after Bush's re-election
the deep state doesn't anyone remember
the Bush administration actually
launching an FBI probe to target leakers
within the administration and in
Congress remember special prosecutor
Patrick Fitzgerald appointed by one
James B Comey to investigate the Bush
administration leaks regarding Valerie
Plame in October 2003 Bush told his top
officials to quote/unquote stop the
leaks to the press and that ordered
promptly leaked to the press here's the
difference between Trump and the rest of
these Republican targets Trump they all
have the same enemies but those enemies
did not include mitt romney or john
mccain or george w bush trump is better
at directly confronting the media than
any of these other Republicans but his
full frontal assault has really achieved
not much since he's unable to control
himself he substitutes his own fibs for
theirs he undermines his credibility
dramatically he undercuts the
credibility of his own surrogate yes
he's helped trip down the media which is
great but he's ripping himself down at
the same time and thereby restoring
American faith in the media here's the
sad fact over the last week the New York
Times in the Washington Post have been
much more credible than the Trump
administration Trump has a base of
Republicans who won't support him but
it's far far smaller than that of Bush
or McCain a Romney in fact unlike Bush's
base Trump space isn't dependent on
anything Trump does Bush's approval
ratings drops into the basement when he
pursued bad policy
remains really high among Republicans
even as he pursues the Cleavon little
and Blazing Saddles strategy of
negotiation
he's currently riding at seventy nine
percent approval rating among
Republicans with just 16 percent
disapproving spineless Republicans
refusing to do his legislative bidding
that's really not the problem the
problem is that he doesn't have a
legislative agenda and that he has not a
lot of leverage with which to bargain
with Republicans thanks to the
incompetence Bush had a share of
Republican naysayers for sure but he
didn't spend his days offering them
excuses to run for the hills finally
there's the deep State Bush had leaks
but Bush locked down leaks as peggy
noonan wrote at the time quote the Bush
White House doesn't leak because george
w actively an affirmative lee does not
want it to Trump hasn't filled the vast
majority of top roles meaning Obama
holdovers likely still dominate his
administration Trump also has no habit
of instilling loyalty and those around
him by pursuing an agenda or listening
to advice or demonstrating he'll stand
by his people instead he's showing he is
willing to throw anybody under the bus
at any time it's an easy silly game to
pretend the Trump's main opposition is
the same opposition all Republicans face
even if that opposition is amped up this
time around Trump's main opposition
remains himself and the sycophants who
insist his only problem is that he's
such a suffering martyr I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
I know pretty harsh on Trump right well
you know that they have now issued a
special prosecutor special counsel in
the Trump case and this is entirely a
prompt own making I want to get to the
fact that all of this seems to be a bit
of a witch-hunt about nothing but we'll
talk about what's real and what's not in
all of this again I think it's important
to note the Trump shot himself in the
foot and the only reason that his foot
is now separated from his body is
because he pulled the trigger but we'll
get to that in just a second first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at lyft
so my wife is a doctor as I've mentioned
a thousand times on the program and that
means she comes home very late at night
sometimes and she's too tired to drive
and that's why she calls uplift that's
why she uses the lyft app right now if
you go to lift calm slash capiro they're
actually looking for drivers so it's not
just about people who want to use lyft
as riders everyone wants to use lyft as
a rider because with this fantastic they
have the best drivers they have the best
cars all the cars are clean everybody
goes through a check but now they're
looking for new drivers because they
actually have so much demand so many
people are using lifts that they want
new drive that they want actually new
drivers when you drive for the right
right chair at ride-sharing app every
trip feels good and lyft is the way to
do it
they're the ride-sharing company that
believes in treating its people better
if you are a lyft driver you're a happy
driver they believe the ride-sharing
driver should actually have fun while
they're on the job
lyft unlike other apps offers in-app
tipping so that means that if you do a
good job then you're going to make more
money because people are going to tip
you when you drive for lyft to keep 100%
of the tips drivers have actually been
paid 150 million dollars in tips since
the feature was introduced express pay
let's drivers get paid almost instantly
instead of waiting for weeks lyft has
even taken the guesswork out of pickups
the new a and P device uses color coding
to help passengers find their drivers
that means that when you drive up in
there are a thousand lift cars then the
person who's waiting for you can find
you more easily you can learn hundreds
of dollars a week plus tips you want to
make more money drive more it's really
easy to give yourself away so join the
ride-sharing company that reaches people
better lifts accomplish slash capiro
today and you actually get five hundred
bucks right off the bat lift calm /
appear you get a $500 new driver bonus
that's lyft calm / Shapiro Lipscomb use
that bat that slash Shapiro and
become a driver for lyft and you get a
$500 new driver bonus as soon as you're
approved it's a limited time only in
terms do
apply but it's pretty solid deal
live.com / up here I'll become a driver
now supplement your income and it can be
fun as well I mean I talked to lyft
drivers all the time since I'm
constantly a passenger and they seem
pretty happy with what they're doing so
check it out Lipscomb slash camp hero
you get that five hundred dollar new
driver bonus ok so the big news of the
day is that a special prosecutor special
counsel has now been appointed in this
investigation of Trump Russia again I
want to say there is no evidence that
Trump is guilty with regards to
collusion with Russia there let me
repeat that again there is no evidence
that Trump is guilty with regard to
collusion with Russia in any way shape
or form no evidence has been presented
this is all smoke it's no fire there are
people who are looking pretty shady
right now Mike Flynn is former national
security adviser as one of them will
talk about Flynn in a little while here
Paul Manta Ford is former campaign
manager is another but if this Watergate
no it's not Watergate it looks like he's
going to be a scandal it's gonna be much
more like around control where it looks
like subordinate did something and the
president doesn't necessarily know about
it this is a case where Trump it really
looks like Trump agenda I understand why
Trump is upset I understand why Trump is
tweeting this morning Trump was tweeting
if I were him I'd be tempted to do it
too is the truth Trump went out there
this morning and he was tweeting that
Hillary was there was never a spotter
special prosecutor associated with
Hillary Clinton there's never a special
prosecutor under Obama there's never a
special counsel he spelled it wrong but
he's right there's never special counsel
that was that was appointed for Benghazi
or fast and furious in case in which the
DOJ clearly could not investigate itself
or on the IRS scandal he's absolutely
right about all of those things and if
your Trump and you're sitting there in
the White House going I didn't have
anything to do with any of these things
why is everybody bothering me about this
yes you two would be irritated but the
fact that Trump can't control himself is
why we now have a special prosecutor
because let's rewind the reason that
this happened in the first place is
because Donald from fire James Comey
that's why we there is now a special
prosecutor remember James Comey with the
guy in charge of investigating all this
stuff
Trump didn't like and was impatient with
the fact that Comey wouldn't just say
that Trump was innocent even if Flynn
and manna Ford and others were still
involved in an investigation so he fired
call me on the recommendation of rod
Rosenstein the Deputy Attorney General
because he had to come up with this
cover of using the Deputy Attorney
General's letter rod Rosenstein s letter
to fire Comey and then Trump came out
two days later and came out
wasn't about that letter at all it was
really about the Russia stuff well now
rod Rosenstein can't be involved in the
Trump Russia investigation because Trump
has now involved him in it in a witness
capacity because now rod Rosenstein will
probably be called in this case if there
is a case at all it'll probably be
subpoenaed and be brought before
Congress to talk about what he knows
about the Trump Russia investigation and
whether there was an attempt to stifle
it or why komen was fired so Rosenstein
can actually be involved so because
Trump fired Comey made up an excuse and
then debunked his own excuse now
Rosenstein has to basically recuse
himself sessions already had to recuse
himself now Rosenstein has to recuse
himself which means that he basically
has to appoint a special counsel so this
is all because Trump just decided to
make a decision without a thought for
the consequences now here's the truth
this could actually be a good thing for
Trump the special counsel thing could
actually be a good thing for Trump if
and only if Trump can control himself
this is always the big question can from
control himself the reason that this
could be a good thing for Trump is
because the person who is in charge here
is going to be a guy named Robert
Mueller Robert Mueller if you recall was
the head of the FBI under george w bush
and then he was reappointed for a couple
of years by President Obama he worked in
the Department of Justice for a dozen
years of you as a US Attorney he was an
assistant attorney general under George
HW Bush in 2004 as director of the FBI
Mueller along with Connolly who's at the
time deputy AG offered to resign from
office if the White House overruled the
DOJ ruling that domestic wiretapping
without a court warrant was
unconstitutional so Mueller is
professional he's 72 years old he's not
going to want this investigation to drag
on forever
now what does the Special Counsel mean
there are a lot of people who are
opposed to the basic concept of a
special counsel and that's for a good
reason
that's for a good reason okay special
counsels have a long history of
exceeding their mandate so Patrick
Fitzgerald's I mentioned earlier was a
special counsel appointed to look into
the leaks about Valerie Plame you
remember this Valerie Plame was working
at the CIA and her husband Joe Wilson
ran a story about how there had never
been yellowcake sold to the Iraqis and
it was kind of a shoddy story but
somebody leaked his wife's name to the
press Valerie Plame and she was working
for the CIA at the time it turned out
that was richard armitage was working
for the administration but patrick
fitzgerald didn't prosecute Armitage he
went all the way to scooter
and then prosecuted him for basically
catching him in supposed perjury
so the problem special prosecutors kind
of star on the on the right you know
with regard to molinsky investigation or
Patrick Fitzgerald on the left the
problem with with a special prosecutor
is a special prosecutors basic job is to
dig and dig and dig until you hit
bedrock and if you don't hit bedrock you
just hit more dirt you just keep digging
so they're going to dig until they find
something which is why the Wall Street
Journal has come out against the
appointment of the special counsel the
special prosecutor now Trump can fire
him the problem is of course that it
from fired him it would just redouble
the pressure on the scandal but here's
why this could be good news for Trump
number one Mueller has a history of
keeping his mouth shut he is not leaked
you I can't like James Comey so he is
not going to be out there every day in
the press talking about what his
investigation is doing and in fact he's
not even answerable under the law to the
Attorney General as far as informing him
as to what is going on on a regular
basis so theoretically Mueller could
just say to everybody okay everybody
calm down
everybody shut up I'm looking into all
this stuff I'm looking into all of it
and we'll get to the bottom of it so sit
down shut up wait here I'll be back
right and then Trump any time somebody
asked him a question stay listen there's
a special prosecutor a special counsel
looking at this and because special
counsel is looking at this I have
nothing else to say on this matter I'm
sure he'll do a thorough job that's what
Trump could say it would probably go
away for a year and we're going to go
quiet the Democrats wouldn't have any
reason to complain because Bob Mueller
is well respected on both sides of the
aisle
it could take pressure off Congress for
subpoenaing people because now they
could say listen knew what is doing the
job it's not our job to do it let me
able to do it so it could really be a
good thing for Trump in a weird sort of
way but Trump has to stop shooting
himself in the foot so him going on
Twitter I understand why he's frustrated
but him going on Twitter this morning in
talking about how he's the most
persecuted president in the history of
President it's not helpful it makes him
look like he's desperate it makes him
look like he's angry it makes him look
like he has something to hide
if he really has nothing to hide his
statement yesterday was the right
statement he made a statement yesterday
from the White House where he said
listen we'll do a full investigation and
they'll come up with nothing as I'm sure
every other investigation well as well
and I'm focused on the work of the
American people that was the proper
answer shoulda left it at that instead
instead he started tweeting this morning
about how he was the this is the biggest
which hunts in the history of the
presidency again you know that it is
true that the media have amped up their
game for Trump for sure but this is not
good strategy I'm just putting aside the
truth of it for a second it's not a good
strategy if you're the President of the
United States your best bet now is you
sit down shut up
let the investigation take its course
they're not going to find anything on
you so let it go instead it just seems
like chaos is raining even Tucker
Carlson who's obviously a fan of the
administration
he was upset at the administration last
night because they'd offered Kellyanne
Conway to come on the air and then
Kellyanne Conway pulled out last second
here's what tucker carlson had to say
about it they said we want to send
overcometh great and then not long
before air they cancelled it for reasons
that weren't exactly clear now I think a
lot of the descriptions in the press
about what's going on at the White House
are false or they're animated by the
hate the press has for Trump which is
totally real but it does seem little
chaotic over there I got to be honest is
it as chaotic as it seems I was over
there today I have to say it was like
whenever you get like inside the bubble
it's so much more tranquil people are
just like doing their jobs nobody's
running around I think if you take a
step away from their daily jobs this is
a lot on a White House staff and this is
more breaking news around an
administration we've seen and I don't
know if we've ever seen it before and I
think that comes with a certain amount
of stress yeah that's on these folks and
they also have to the point here that
Carlson is obviously upset because the
White House is not handling its business
properly again the White House could
come out of this it's so easy here it
really is and it's been easy every step
of the way because self created problems
are also problems you can solve yourself
Trump is capable of solving these
problems all he has to do appoint a
director of the FBI who's going to be a
bipartisan pick and then appoint
somebody and then let the special
prosecutor do his job
that's it that's it that's all he has to
do we'll talk about whether he's going
to do that in just a second first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
CSO so there's a brand new show over at
sea so calm it's called hidden America
with Jonah ray it's a travel show where
the places are real but the people
definitely aren't it's a comedic journey
through America that's a Travel Show
parody which is basically making fun of
Anthony Bourdain which is totally worth
while since I think Anthony Bourdain is
kind of a schmuck so this is really it's
a very very funny show and see so as
lots of funny shows they have plenty of
big names who are creating shows now
stand-up comedy from all of your
favorite comics Louie CK is my personal
favorite comic he may be on left but he
is freaking hilarious and they have all
of the stand-up classics from Louie CK
and in big Jay oakerson it basically of
all of your favorite comics are at sea
so calm and if you go over there right
now and use promo code Ben you get one
month for free they've got the entire
backlog of Saturday Night Live the
entire Mountain Python catalog they have
as I say both seasons of hidden America
with Jonah ray they have a debut TV
series from from my brother my brother
and means the McElroy brothers they have
all sorts of just great comedy so if you
need a laugh and you need a break which
is I think where a lot of people are at
where I'm at these days then you need to
go to see SOCOM and subscribe you can
get its content anytime using iOS
Android Roku Amazon fire TV Apple TV
windows or even Xbox one is 399 per
month 399 per month for all of that
comedy again it's C SOCOM se ESO comm my
wife and I watch it pretty much every
night sign up right now you get one
month free with promo code Ben at
checkout it's the comedy that you need
they've got all the late night shows
again I think everybody needs to lighten
up a little bit right now and see SOCOM
is one way to make sure that that
happened goes go over to see SOCOM use
that promo code Ben so that they know
that we sent you and also so you can get
that one month for free okay so well the
the Democrats meanwhile are pushing on
the Comey stuff so now the Democrats are
basically silenced on the Trump Russia
investigation as far as Mueller so
Mueller is looking into it there's
nothing for them to talk about but
they're amping up their game with
regards to the Comey firing so remember
it's it they're going to focus in on the
supposed to cover up not on the supposed
crime again for the fourth time this
show there is no evidence that Trump
personally colluded with Russia in any
way zero evidence whatsoever so what are
they focusing on they're focusing on the
supposed to cover-up of evidence that
they have no proof exists and then
focusing on Trump firing Comey as I said
yesterday what actually happened in the
firing of Co me in all likelihood was
that Trump thinks that Mike Flynn is
innocent and so he asked Comey can you
leave him alone not because he thinks
Flint is guilty and wants then once Co
me off his case but because he thinks
playing is innocent she's thinking to
leave them alone Comey says well not
really and then a couple months later
Trump is pissed because Comey won't
say that Trump is innocent and so Trump
fires call me and then he handles it
really really badly so the Democrats are
jumping on the Comey fire ring to
suggest to cover up even though there
really is not even evidence of a
cover-up yet it's really over the top so
the Democrats are focused on bringing
Comey before Congress and talking about
coming as much as possible mark Warner
senator from from Virginia he says that
the American people want to hear from
combing the thing that the American
public wants to hear is they want to
hear from Jim Comey they want to hear
and from him an open hearing and I think
the appropriate venues the Senate Intel
committee if you choose another
committee that's fine as well but as
long as he gets a cat that chance to
make his case okay so the Democrats are
jumping all over this and the white
house again is handling this about as
badly as you possibly can Sean Spicer
White House press secretary at least for
the moment he says that the White House
has nothing to say about the news that
broke yesterday about the James Comey
memo the memo that suggested that that
he had been told by Trump to drop the
investigation or the Trump and suggested
you drop the investigation here Sean
Spicer basically ignoring it we know we
don't have that to spy so sorry so
Spicer actually said that and then but
here's the truth here's the truth okay
easy answer to all of this easy answer
Comey said in open testimony that people
were not trying to quash his
investigation that people were not
trying to get in his way here is a
flashback James Comey like a week ago
talking about how he was never pressured
to halt his investigation if the
Attorney General or senior officials at
the Department of Justice opposes a
specific investigation can they halt
that FBI investigation in theory yes as
it happened not in my experience because
it would be a big deal to tell the FBI
to stop doing something that without a
appropriate purpose
we're oftentimes they give us opinions
that we don't see a case there and so
you ought to stop investing resources in
it but I'm talking about a situation
where we were told to stop something for
a political reason that would be a very
big deal okay so oh so right he said an
open testimony people weren't trying to
stop him now people on left are saying
well he was talking about the Attorney
General you really think that if he was
asked that question and he wanted to say
the president's been trying to stop me
from investigating he couldn't drop it
right there so Comey himself is saying
that he wasn't really pressured to drop
this FBI in
negation why isn't the White House
pushing that line the Democrats are out
over their skis here they're really out
over their skis jason Chaffetz he's
going to be retiring this congressman
from Utah had to the House Oversight
Committee he says and he's right the
Democrats don't have anything here they
really don't so do you think that the
appointment of robert muller as special
counsel to look into this russia
question whatever that question is will
start the acceleration we've seen in the
last week talk of impeachment of
removing Trump somehow know just why
would it not know it's not going to slow
them down now they're just going to
change their talking points the
Democrats by the way I love their
newfound commitment to openness
transparency and accountability I mean
where did that come from all of a sudden
that January 20th they are all for it
but they're just going to change their
talking points and say this
administration is in chaos and by the
way it's under investigation itself it
had to have a special counsel you'll
hear them even you can just already hear
them in advance
it's an insatiable desire they have no
idea it's totally right it's just
totally right the D the special
prosecutor isn't going to make the
Democrats feel any better but it's at
least it's at least a good cover for the
Trump administration if the Trump
administration is willing to use it now
I do want to talk about where the Trump
administration is vulnerable on all of
this but for that you're gonna have to
go over to Daley wire.com and become a
subscriber for $8 a month YouTube can be
a subscriber at Daley wire.com you can
see the rest of the show live and you
can check it out annually and get a free
copy of Jeremy borings at the Arroyo
fictional film what modern Westerners
sent on the southern border battle ranch
are trying to defend his land from the
drug cartels again daily wire.com is
where you go if you want to become a
subscriber we do appreciate by the way
you subscribing it helps us make this
show possible every every day it helps
us bring it to you at the top-notch
quality to which you have become
accustomed we will be having beautiful
new studios by the way in the near
future and that will also be because our
subscribers have joined our team and so
we always appreciate that if you don't
want to subscribe right now you just
want to listen a little bit later then
go over to iTunes or SoundCloud make
sure that you hit the subscribe button
and then make sure that you make sure
that you leave us a review we always
appreciate it we are the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
you